bienvenue à tous bienvenue sur Parlement
Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actu politique et parlementaire ravi
de vous retrouver
et dans l'actualité cette semaine une
rentrée parlementaire sous haute tension
pour le Premier ministre d'un côté
Manuel Valls rappelle des troupes avant
le vote de confiance mardi prochain il
appelle les frondeurs à prendre le
responsabilité de l'autre il doit faire
face à l'affaire thévenou il quitte PS
mais refuse de lâcher son siège de
député
l'exécutif qui est également à la peine
sur le front économique les chiffres ne
sont pas bons une croissance en panne et
un nouveau dérapage des finances
publiques l'engagement de réduire le
déficit à 3% du produit intérieur bouton
2015 et renvoyé à 2017 et peuvent nous
emmèneront au théâtre nous parlerons
politique au plus précisément de ceux
qui entourent les politiques une pièce
écrite par le scénariste de House of
cardos connaissait cette fameuse série
américaine elle est jouée en ce moment
au théâtre héberto à Paris c'est le plus
de l'hebdo
et pour commenter cette actualité
chargée et mouvementée notre invité
cette semaine et Jean-Christophe
Cambadélis bonjour bonjour député de
Paris et premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste alors avant de réagir à
l'actualité c'est la tradition de cette
émission je vous propose d'entendre ce
que pense de vous et ce que pense de
votre action certains de vos collègues à
l'Assemblée
l'homme a une carrure plus à même de
tenir le parti le Parti socialiste alors
c'est peut-être la référence à un passé
un peu fougueux mais je crois réellement
qu'il est davantage carlm désir amène
d'apporter une structure différente au
Parti socialiste d'ailleurs on le voit
déjà un petit peu aujourd'hui il y a une
mission impossible pour Jean-Christophe
cabelladélis actuellement et je crois
qu'il ne faut pas trop lui faire porter
sur les épaules les responsabilités
d'une situation qu'il est impossible de
remonter je pense à cette citation du
cardinal de Ré qui disait les des
moments où il est impossible de bien
faire et ben je crois que
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis est dans un
moment de cette nature là vous avez la
carrure pour maîtriser la situation j'en
crise encore valise vous allez nous
arranger tout ça
c'est mon travail
dans la situation est difficile tous les
Français le voient elle est difficile
sur le plan économique et pas simplement
en France elle est difficile sur le plan
politique on est quand même dans une
situation
décomposition politique d'un certain
point de vue et on va peut-être en
parler
elle est difficile aussi parce que
les désaccords sont pas net entre les
formations politiques et à l'intérieur
des formations donc pour les Français
tout ça c'est un peu le brouillard un
moment donné vous avez pas envie de
jeter l'éponge et de stop basta cette
rentrée c'est terrible non parce que je
crois que à travers cette rentrée
broussailleuse brumeuse plein de
tonnerre et de souffle
il y a des éléments qui sont
intéressants et puis il y a des enjeux
considérables ce qui se passe en Irak ce
qui se passe au niveau du terrorisme ce
qui se passe au niveau économique omique
tout ça nécessite que le Parti
socialiste soit à la hauteur de sa tâche
allez on va commencer par lundi parce
que la semaine ça commence toujours par
lundi et le FN est au port de pouvoir
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
premier ministre
alors qu'un sondage d'anne-marine Le Pen
gagnante au premier tour en 2017 la
classe politique est en pleine crise
mais elle réagit est-ce le retour pour
autant de ce que l'on appelle le Front
républicain on voit ça avec Mounir aussi
Marine Le Pen démarre l'année sur une
bonne note des enquêtes d'opinion la
place en tête des prétendantes pour
l'Élysée en 2017 cette hypothèse lui
donne une confiance qu'elle tentait
d'insuffler ce week-end aux jeunes de
son parti à Fréjus pour leur université
d'été notre progression est déjà
spectaculaire
peut un UMPS mettra face à nous nous
gagnerons cette assurance inquiète
l'exécutif affaibli par une semaine
chaotique Manuel Valls en déplacement en
Italie a lancé un message d'alerte pour
remobiliser ses troupes face aux FN
nous savons quel serait le prix terrible
de notre échec en France l'extrême
droite et Marine Le Pen sont en portent
du pouvoir
et moi en tant qu'homme de gauche je ne
pourrais jamais me résigner à cela
une dramatisation de la situation
présente aussi à l'UMP plusieurs
responsables de l'opposition
osleton pour dénoncer les positions du
parti de Marine Le Pen il faut attaquer
beaucoup plus fermement que nous le
faisons les idées des Front National qui
sont pernicieusement la France moi je ne
veux pas d'une France Paris cadet et
fermé à l'étranger comme il l'a propose
et puis ensuite il faut réunir nos
forces parce que si nous avons divisé au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le pire est possible démo
fort qui auront du mal à porter dans
l'opinion tant que les deux principales
forces politiques du pays resteront
pétrées dans leur division interne
alors à La Rochelle lors de votre
discours de clôture vous disiez que il y
avait un vrai risque pour que Marine Le
Pen puisse gagner l'élection
présidentielle ça veut dire quoi que le
Front républicain et c'est fini c'est
terminé il est mort écoutez vous le
voyez dans les sondages à force de dire
à force que le MP dise que le PS et le
front
nationalp ne veut pas choisir entre le
PS et le Front national donc petit à
petit nous avons une situation où
l'électorat de droite ne se reporte plus
sur les le candidat socialiste on le
voit au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle lorsqu'il y a des
sondages qui sont faits et de l'autre
côté il est évident que les socialistes
ou la gauche d'une manière générale ont
du mal à se retrouver derrière une
droite qui est de plus en plus
tachérienne et encore en plus si c'est
Sarkozy comme candidat vous imaginez
donc Marine Le Pen avec 30% c'est ce
qu'elle a fait aux élections européennes
au deuxième tour et
instrumentalisation vous l'entendez un à
droite comme à gauche certains
mais je crois qu'ils ont ils ont tort on
a une petite j'ai dit ça dans mon
discours il y a une espèce de musique
qui me fait penser à juin 40 rien ne se
passera rien ne se passe bon bien voilà
à la fin
Alain Juppé à raison quand il dit que
droite et gauche sont aussi en partie
responsables de de la situation parce
qu'ils de son pas capables par exemple
de mobiliser leur électorat c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont une part de
responsabilité qu'il ne faut pas
dénoncer la possibilité que Marine Le
Pen l'emporte oui il y a une
responsabilité de la droite et de la
gauche il y a une responsabilité de
gestion il y a une responsabilité de
perdre d'espoir pour la gauche il y a
une responsabilité de division il y a
une responsabilité de gestion etc oui il
y a une responsabilité mais c'est pas au
nom de cette responsabilité que l'on
doit pas combattre la montée du Front
national du pouvoir en tout cas
proche de façon d'entrée au Palais du
Luxembourg les élections auront lieu le
28 septembre prochain le parti de Marine
Le Pen va essayer de miser sur des
plateformes comme le Var comme les
Bouches-du-Rhône nous sommes allés à la
rencontre du maire de Fréjus David
rachnil pourrait faire son entrée au
Sénat Julie Hulin quand un calmer
bonjour vous allez bien c'est ce
personnage médiatique qui a choisi le
Front national pour décrocher un siège
au Sénat il avait d'abord refusé
préférence se consacrer à sa ville
Marine Le Pen la convaincu la commission
nationale d'investiture du Front
national a souhaité
partout il y avait des mers
dans les départements que ce soit des
maires qui a discuté avec les grands
électeurs parce qu'ils avaient peut-être
une connaissance particulière du terrain
des difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontées les maires
et quel courrier on envoie à quel
secteur aussi
parce que pour les courriers thématiques
spécifiques il veut montrer
l'implication et l'importance de
l'implication et de l'implantation
surtout du Front national dans le
territoire varois-est varois notamment
a-t-il des chances à la Législative
incontestablement
au sénatorial à mon avis beaucoup moins
évidemment puisqu'il n'y a quand même
pas un nombre d'élus suffisant je pense
pour le porter au Palais du Luxembourg
David Rachline et son équipe
et notamment sur une réforme
territoriale qui a du mal à passer leur
défi ce familiariser avec une élection
pas comme les autres et c'est la mise en
place de vrais structures compétente qui
vont à la rencontre des autres élus mais
il y a aussi une différence c'est que
maintenant les élus quel que soit
l'étiquette politique nous reçoivent
dans un esprit républicain alors
qu'avant ils étaient beaucoup plus
souvent dans un esprit polémique donc
c'est vrai que c'est une facilite aussi
un petit peu la tâche quand même s'il
devenait sénateur David Racheline le
promet il restera mère il devra alors
rendre des comptes à un Front National
qui rejette fermement le cumul des
mandats
alors que pèse réellement le Front
national son pouvoir est-il exagéré
c'est le zoom de la semaine
et nous accueillons Thomas Guénolé
bonjour vous êtes politologue professeur
maître de conférence à Sciences Po et
vous avez notamment publié ce livre un
petit guide du mensonge en politique des
mensonges il y en a beaucoup en ce
moment est-ce que ce nouveau sondage sur
le FN c'est un mensonge ça aussi est-ce
que le résultat du FN n'est pas exagéré
surestimé si on parle de résultats à la
présidentielle il y a trois problèmes
qui se posent qui font que en conscience
on ne devrait pas se servir de ses
sondages quel que soit le gagnant pas
parce que le Front National est affiché
à tel ou tel score 1 les intentions de
vote se stabilisent trois mois avant
l'échéance donc là vous avez un taux de
non-réponse ou d'indécision qui est trop
élevé de les marges d'erreur on en parle
jamais sont beaucoup trop fortes c'est
plus -3 points quand vous avez mis le
sonder donc quand vous avez Marine Le
Pen à 28 et Sarkozy à 25 en réalité ils
sont égalité et vous devez pas annoncer
Marine Le Pen en tête non mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et trois il y
a un certain nombre d'institudes de
sondage qui n'affichent pas dans les
résultats qu'il donne le taux de
non-réponse et quand vous prenez contre
le taux de non-réponse l'échantillon qui
s'est exprimé devient trop faible pour
prendre en compte les résultats les
instituts de sondage eux-mêmes savent
que ce que je suis en train de dire est
vrai alors
quel pouvoir on parle c'est notorial je
suis d'accord avec votre reportage c'est
à dire qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment des
locaux pour pouvoir faire passer un
sénateur cette fois-ci en revanche pour
les régionales moi j'ai fait des
estimations mon hypothèse de départ
c'était de dire qu'au régional de 2010
les comportements de vote des
européennes de 2009 avaient été les
mains avaient été avaient été reproduite
et que donc au régional de 2015 les gens
voteront comme aux européennes de 2014
actuellement sur l'écran alors sur la
base de quoi ces projections simplement
une extrapolation
européennes parce que la dernière fois
les gens avaient voté aux régionales
comme ils avaient voté aux européennes
et donc le résultat que j'obtiens c'est
en utilisant les règles du scrutin que
les gens ne connaissent pas mais pour
les gens qui connaissent les règles de
mode scrutin vous savez comme moi que la
liste arrivée en tête au second tour à
une prime de 25% des sièges et grâce à
cette le Front national en faisant 36%
en or Picardie et en faisant 32 de
mémoire en PACA au 32 ou 34 je ne sais
plus 33 c'est ça il se retrouve à
prendre le contrôle de deux régions pour
autant j'insiste là-dessus ce n'est ça
va être paradoxal ce que je vais dire
mais ce n'est pas une progression du
Front national le Front national ou ne
gagne pas en pourcentage d'inscrit ce
qui se passe c'est que son taux de
mobilisation de son réservoir électoral
est supérieure à la participation
moyenne et donc avec un taux d'inscrit
assez faible en réalité en suffrage
exprimé il fait un carton on reprend
dans l'ordre l'entrée du FN au Sénat
c'est possible pour vous ou pas je pense
pas mais vous savez à partir du moment
où cette formation politique s'installe
dans le paysage politique elle aura du
succès dans tous les compartiments du
jeu vous pensez vraiment qu'elle peut
s'installer demain que c'est une réalité
30% ou plus aux élections européennes
c'est qu'on est installé
un échec au contraire quelque chose de
normal finalement c'est un échec mais
c'est pas le sujet parce que pour cela
il faut avoir des élus et ils sont en
des élus locaux ils sont en bois
d'implantation ils ne sont pas en ce
moment dans une situation où il y a un
différentiel entre leur potentiel
et leur implantation
leur potentiel est plus fort que leur
implantation bon donc c'est un une
formation qui est en construction en de
ce que j'appelle moi en dynamique ça
serait normal mais je pense que c'est
trop tôt et sur le sondage qu'on vient
de voir ça ne m'étonne pas je sais pas
si les comportements se reproduiront
parce que les régions ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes et les socialistes ne
sont pas tout à fait dans la même
situation parce que ils sont sortants et
le scrutin européen n'est pas le scrutin
pour les socialistes j'entends n'est pas
le scrutin le scrutin régional c'est pas
tout à fait pareil le le rapport de nos
présidents sortant vis-à-vis de la
population choix dans Midi-Pyrénées par
exemple ou dans le doc Roussillon je
vois cela en Île-de-France ou dans
certains endroits mais il est vrai qu'il
gagne menace et il faut pas le nier on
va continuer merci beaucoup Thomas
Guénolé pour cette analyse et ce zoom
sur le FN on va passer au mardi sur
Christophe les frondeurs ils annoncent
la couleur
Manuel Valls a tapé du poisson la table
jouer la dramatisation appelée la
responsabilité de chacun mais rien n'y
fait les fraudeurs ont décidé de
s'abstenir la semaine prochaine lors du
vote de confiance rentrée électrique
pour le groupe PS à l'Assemblée
reportage Dream Benamar c'est une
nouvelle épreuve de force qui se joue
entre les murs de l'Assemblée au sein du
groupe socialiste les députés frondeurs
tirent les premiers et devant les
caméras font monter la pression à 6
jours du vote de confiance nous nous
aurions une abstention collective et
nous pensons qu'il n'est pas possible
d'imposer au groupe socialiste une
unanimité de façade en raison de
l'impasse économique et politique dans
lequel on se trouve quelques minutes
plus tard Manuel Valls arrive et tente
de garder le sourire mais devant les
députés socialistes ils se montrent
ferme le Premier ministre n'entend pas
changé de politique à la sortie il
menace les députés frondeurs il faut
être capable de gouverner dans la
dignité et en tenant évidemment le cap
qui celui du redressement du pays moi je
suis convaincu que tous les députés
socialistes sont conscients de cette
réalité à chacun d'entre eux d'être à la
hauteur de la responsabilité combien
seront-ils à a voté la confiance à
Manuel Valls difficile à dire ils
étaient 11 lors du dernier vote de
confiance il devrait être entre 20 et 30
à s'abstenir pas assez tout de même pour
faire chuter le second gouvernement
Valls mais leur chef de fil Bruno Le
Roux en appelle à l'unité j'ai appelé la
majorité en tout cas le groupe
majoritaire a arrêté de surjouer les
différences à arrêter
d'alimenter le débat qui est le débat
que nourri aujourd'hui la droite et
l'extrême droite sur l'illégitimité de
ce gouvernement une rentrée sous tension
et un vote de confiance plus compliqué
que prévu pour Manuel Valls sa majorité
n'a jamais été aussi fragile à gauche
les alliés du Parti socialiste sont
partagés les vers ne se sont pas encore
prononcés les Radicaux de Gauche eux
devraient soutenir le Premier ministre
on verra combien seront les frondeurs à
s'abstenir la semaine prochaine a priori
personne ne va voter contre que dans
votre groupe socialiste mais si c'était
le cas que risquerait aujourd'hui un
frondeur qui vote contre le contre la
confiance du Premier ministre mais
immédiatement dehors et nos statut et je
peux pas faire autrement moi je serai
obligé d'appliquer il serait déféré
devant la commission des conflits sur le
plan de sa fédération et après le
Conseil national entérinerait son
exclusion et vous croyez que la semaine
prochaine il y en a un deux qui
pourraient qui pourrait aller dans la
direction jouer avec ce jeu là
c'est normal la presse fait son travail
elle souligne là où il y a des
différences etc mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de nouveau depuis le mois de juin ce
sont les mêmes
coups un appel de sang parlementaires
qui fragiliserait évidemment à ce
moment-là le problème ministre ce sont
les mêmes qui en juin n'ont pas voté les
textes
ils sont bien installés vous êtes
premier secrétaire du PS vous les avez
en ligne vous en parler qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites qu'est-ce qu'il vous
disent
on a un dialogue moi je leur dis que ce
qu'il demandait en juin à savoir que
l'on ne soit pas subordonné aux 3% nous
l'avons puisque aujourd'hui 3% de
déficit alors eux ils disent que c'est
justement le signe de l'échec de la
politique
économiquement contradictoires
de ne pas être subordonné aux 3% et
quand le gouvernement
on va être à 4% de dire c'est l'échec
donc avant ils étaient donc pour l'échec
d'un dialogue de source je pense qu'il y
a un des accords il y a plein de de
formulations parce que tout le monde
danse sur le volcan médiatique mais il y
a un des accords ce désaccord c'est la
part que l'on fournit
au ménage et aux entreprises il y en a
un sujet important
ce débat là il a lieu dans tous les
groupes parlementaires dans toute
l'Europe
quand même sur un sujet aussi important
pour moi bien sûr
on l'a déjà voté deux fois sur le sujet
deux fois ils ont été battus et c'est
pas pour autant qu'ils ont
accepté la loi de la majorité bon bah il
faut faire avec mais je crois que
ce que je viens de dire sur les 3% les
propositions du Premier ministre sur
l'investissement qui était une demande
du Parti socialiste ce qui va se faire
sur les impôts avec la légère le fait
que la Banque centrale européenne fait
un peu de faire un peu d'inflation les
300 milliards de Monsieur jungkur etc
tout ça va
décrisper on va dire le débat politique
en notre sein et je pense qu'on va
pouvoir
si la majorité est courte le Premier
ministre devra peut-être
légiférer par le ce qu'on appelle le
49-3 un petit peu plus vite et ce qui
est que vous y êtes favorable ou pas
le premier ministre utilise tous les
éléments qui viennent de la Constitution
c'est pour pas pour moi un problème on a
jamais
critiqué Michel Rocard d'avoir
fonctionné comme cela même on applaudit
on parle d'un autre sujet l'homme du
jour ou plutôt l'ombre de la semaine
tomate et venoue l'éphémère secrétaire
d'État au Commerce extérieur est
toujours député mais personne ne sait où
il est il a été exclu du groupe
socialiste et la pression monte François
moulin
Ops ce mardi la gêne est palpable certes
Thomas thévenou quitte le parti et le
groupe parlementaire mais l'élu de
Saône-et-Loire conservent son siège
contre vents et marées quitta embarrassé
ses anciens collègues j'aurais souhaité
qu'il aille plus loin dans sa décision
maintenant moi je n'ai pas cette
capacité personne ne l'a d'ailleurs il
est maintenant seul avec sa conscience
et c'est à lui de décider ce qu'il fait
de son mandat de parlementaire
sa conscience très peu de voix s'élèvent
au PS pour prendre la défense du député
moi je ne mets pas sur le même plan des
armans individuels qui peuvent arriver
parce que nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes donc nous avons aussi nos
imperfections avec un système de fraudes
généralisé comme et le système Bygmalion
UMP sarkozycopé voilà qui pour moi n'est
pas de la même nature à l'UMP justement
les élus s'étonnent que Thomas thévenou
garde son siège et demande une enquête
fiscale il y a aucune raison qui puisse
être à l'Assemblée nationale moi je
siège dans l'hémicycle j'en ai assez que
des gens comme ça monsieur Cahuzac
Monsieur Strauss-Kahn projette une image
de tous pourris sur nous monsieur
thévenou n'a pas sa place à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est tout le député de
Saône-et-Loire devrait désormais siéger
avec les non inscrits dans l'hémicycle
petite consolation pour le Parti
socialiste comme Thomas thévenourès il
n'y aura pas de législatif partielle
pour le remplacer et donc le risque de
perdre un siège dans une majorité
fragile est écartée
à l'Assemblée nationale il a réagi très
vivement écouté le comportement de
tomate est venu
les faits
qui lui sont reprochés son attitude ça
désinvolture on fait mal à la République
à la France et aussi à la gauche
alors qu'une immense majorité de nos
concitoyens et nous le savons et je le
dis avec
gravité considère à tort bien sûr que la
plupart des responsables politiques de
ce pays sont corrompus une telle
attitude et des armantes et révoltantes
elle est impardonnable
une seule question est-ce que vous avez
eu tomate et Venou au téléphone est-ce
qu'il vous a dit qu'il démissionnerait
d'ailleurs c'est son communiqué son
communiqué commence par ces mots c'est
quand même formidable le débat
médiatique le communiqué de l'AFP
commence par ces mots j'ai rencontré le
Premier secrétaire qui m'a demandé de
démissionner l'Assemblée nationale bon
donc même lui il l'écrit et
vous avez remarqué qu'il n'a pas voulu
démissionner je lui ai demandé il n'a
pas voulu bon il a quitté le parti
socialiste
et le groupe socialiste mais vous savez
c'est un homme qui est aujourd'hui
aux abois c'est quelqu'un qui est dans
une situation difficile ils sont en
compte petit à petit de ce non seulement
de ce qu'il a fait mais des conséquences
de son geste et moi je pense qu'il
démissionnera je pense que la thermie
d'émissionnera il va s'en rendre compte
petit à petit de la situation il va
rencontrer ses camarades sur le terrain
c'est les militants des sections
socialistes vont lui parler et je suis à
peu près persuadé qu'il en tirera les
conséquences au moment venu vous allez
le rappeler peut-être
pour l'instant j'ai pas prévu de de le
rappeler je voudrais savoir quelque
chose qu'est-ce qui ne va pas en ce
moment dans votre majorité qu'est-ce qui
va pas beaucoup de choses la Ferté
genoux
ça va tous les jours il se passe quelque
chose donc c'est le trait de la
situation ça ne m'avait pas échappé
vous savez ce qui se passe c'est qu'il y
a des comportements individuels et des
problèmes politiques il ne faut pas
mélanger les comportements individuels
et les problèmes politiques vous votre
rôle c'est de rendre l'information tous
les jours donc à partir de là évidemment
les Français se disent qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur les problèmes politiques on en
a parlé mais bon il est sur les
dérives individuelles on a sanctionné
voilà est-ce qu'il faut que Nicolas
Sarkozy revienne pour que la gauche se
mette enfin en ordre de bataille
le côté Zoro est arrivé ou Zoro va
arriver me fait doucement rire voilà
quelqu'un qui a laissé une ardoise
colossale à la France et qui revient en
disant je vais tout arranger ça y est
vous êtes prêt toutes les l'argumentaire
est prêt les flèches vous avez plus qu'à
les mettre au bout de l'arc il y a même
pas à réfléchir il y a même pas à
réfléchir c'est quasi spontané en tout
cas si revient Nicolas Sarkozy ça peut
vous faire du bien c'est-à-dire que les
projecteurs finalement seront mis sur
lui et on ne parlera peut-être de choses
du Parti Social je vais vous dire de
choses la première c'est que nous
souhaitons que l'UMP soit en capacité de
combattre et soit restructuré soit une
force politique qui agisse parce que
c'est une force républicaine même si
nous la combattons l'adversaire dans la
République ce n'est pas un ennemi
deuxièmement ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que je suis sceptique parce que
cette formation pilo-politique va être
prisonnière de l'éthique contestée de
Nicolas Sarkozy et on va avoir pendant
des semaines les épisodes judiciaires
qui vont abîmer cette formation
politique et dans une situation où la
gauche est en difficulté et la droite va
être abîmée par les affaires de Sarkozy
ça fait une fois de plus le jeu du Front
national pour vos amis de l'opposition
vous le conseillez par contre pas
revenir mais je viens de les prévenir
d'autant que sur le front économique ça
dérape également Michel Sapin a confirmé
cette nouvelle dégradation des comptes
publics français très loin du pacte de
stabilité et pourtant le gouvernement
maintient le cap et promet qu'il n'y
aura pas de nouvelles hausses d'impôts
Jean-Baptiste Daoulas Marie Labat
les chiffres annoncés par Michel Sapin
sont mauvais la croissance en berne elle
ne dépassera pas 0,4% en 2014 pour 2015
Bercy n'espère pas plus de 1% de
croissance conséquence le déficit public
va augmenter avec une prévision de 4,4 %
en 2014 la France ne pourra pas revenir
sous la barre des 3%, avant 2017 la
maîtrise des dépenses est une nécessité
et nous irons jusqu'au bout de
l'objectif de 50 milliards d'économies
prévues jusqu'en 2017 a commencé
évidemment par les 21 milliards
d'économies prévues pour la seule année
pourtant la semaine dernière Michel
Sapin avait annoncé que les 21 milliards
d'économies ne pourraient pas être
atteints en 2015 une volte-face qui
inquiète l'opposition comment
voulez-vous que on croise sérieusement
ce qui est fait et c'est pas le
président d'une une petite association
qui a du mal à boucler son budget c'est
le Ministre de l'économie de la France
donc on a quand même un peu de de on a
des enjeux de crédibilité sur le plan
international comme sur le plan
d'ailleurs interne qui sont extrêmement
importants et tous les jours ils sont
bafoués au PS les frondeurs ne sont pas
plus indulgents avec Michel Sapin selon
eux l'absence de résultats sur la
croissance aurait dû modifier les
objectifs de réduction de dépenses moi
ça me conforte dans l'idée que la
politique économique qu'on mène n'est
pas la plus adaptée pour relancer la
croissance je trouve d'ailleurs assez
finalement étonnant que le gouvernement
le reconnaisse reconnaisse que les la
croissance rapport au rendez-vous et
n'en tirent aucune conclusion sur
l'éventuelle modification de ces
instruments de politique économique la
France reste sous la pression de ses
partenaires européens quelques minutes
après la conférence de presse de Michel
Sapin Angela Merkel appelait l'Europe à
une stricte discipline sur les dépenses
budgétaires
alors le déficit part totalement à la
dérive la France est donc incapable de
tenir ses engagements européens
attendez
prenons l'exemple final à la Merkel nous
dit qu'il faut respecter ce que l'Europe
a voté en termes de déficit mais
l'Allemagne ne l'a pas fait à l'époque
de Schroder ils ont laissé mais
aujourd'hui alors ils ont fait des
réformes en laissant filer les déficits
pourquoi voudriez-vous que nous nous
soyons absolument pas de référence avec
nos défis non ces règles sont idiotes je
les dis j'ai toujours combattu ces 3%
j'ai fait toute ma campagne des
européennes de stabilité et j'ai fait
toute ma campagne européenne sur ce
thème et je trouve aujourd'hui que dans
une phase de déflation il faut tout à la
fois que la Banque centrale européenne
fasse un peu l'inflation face baisser
l'euro et que les économies s'adaptent
il faut arrêter d'être dogmatique on va
pas en l'air réellement la France
pour respecter des critères qui ont été
votés avant la crise est-ce que la
parole de la France sera écoutée alors
même que le jour où Michel Sapa a
annoncé ce nouveau record français les
déficits Pierre Moscovici a été confirmé
au poste de commissaire des affaires
économiques suscitant un peu l'ironie de
la suscitant les critiques de la presse
européenne est-ce que c'est une
provocation de nommée Pierre Moscovici
aux affaires économiques comme le dit
l'Allemagne
en tout cas sa position sera difficile
vu le contexte est un pragmatique c'est
oui c'est vrai vous avez raison il n'est
pas dans la ligne hors d'eau libérale de
Bruxelles et de la commission précédente
c'est un pragmatique qui va être
mais pas simplement lui enfin écoutez
qu'est-ce que disent les Italiens
qu'est-ce que disent sous cap les
Espagnols mais qui se qui font attention
parce qu'ils sont alliés avec Merkel
qu'est-ce que disent aujourd'hui les
Néerlandais qu'est-ce que disent
aujourd'hui les Polonais qu'est-ce que
disent l'ensemble de l'Europe mais
l'ensemble de l'Europe dit il y en a
marre de la situation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on veut de la croissance la
relance qui existe aujourd'hui 21
milliards d'économies à faire en 2015 2
milliards encore à trouver on les trouve
où deux pistes avancées tout d'abord une
taxe sur le diesel de 2 centimes vous
êtes pour ou pas c'est mieux que la TVA
sur ce sujet nous aurons une discussion
nous avons une discussion et j'attends
les propositions du ministre dans ce
domaine je ne sais pas je n'ai pas le
budget entre les mains donc je ne sais
pas quels sont nos marges de manœuvre je
veux le savoir avant de me prononcer le
diesel c'est une bonne piste ou pas je
n'en sais rien vous pensez qu'il reste
vraiment tes marges de manœuvre avec un
tel aventure
ça fait 10 milliards d'euros et vous
pensez d'eux ça fait quand même beaucoup
vous avez les armes pour lutter contre
les fournir juridiquement la fraude à la
TVA vous voyez qu'on n'est pas démunis
et qu'on a des possibilités
que les Français ont voté pour la gauche
et qu'il se retrouve avec un programme
de la droite allemande ça vous fait
réagir IR ça me fait rire ça vous fait
rire et ça me fait rire parce que il est
au gouvernement
si c'était vrai si c'était vrai il a
accepté d'être dans un gouvernement qui
faisait la politique de la droite
allemande non ça m'étonne Arnaud enfin
c'est pas possible
très bien Martine Aubry qui on l'entend
de plus en plus elle refait entendre sa
voix vous serez ce week-end présent avec
elle aux universités d'été de l'homme
dans le Nord elle dit qu'elle veut
absolument faire une réforme fiscale une
réforme fiscale nationale ou locale elle
a raison de s'exprimer maintenant
Martine Aubry on a l'impression que
c'est pas forcément la bienvenue tout de
suite
les gens disaient mais qu'est-ce qu'il
dit on l'entend pas et quand elle
s'exprime on dit pourquoi elle se parle
maintenant on se fait partie d'un peu de
la cacophonie actuelle
si on écoute bien ce qu'elle a dit elle
n'est pas une frondeuse elle veut une
inflexion et la réussite de ce
gouvernement donc à l'inverse qu'elle
peut être un recours pour le PS
je crois pas qu'elle se situe dans cette
situation là
elle veut vraiment que nous réussissions
parce que être un recours dans l'échec
c'est de courir à l'échec et juste aussi
une question vous êtes assez souple en
tout cas visiblement pour faire le grand
écart de Manuel Valls à Martine Aubret
ah ouais je crois je n'ai même pas
besoin d'être souple je pense qu'ils
tirent
sur quelle position vous connaissez
savoir quelques-unes la politique
économique et la politique actuelle du
gouvernement n'était pas forcément la
bonne oui mais est-ce qu'elle a dit ce
qu'elle allait faire
on est on est dans le débat de posture
pour l'instant Martine Aubry a dit qu'il
fallait une inflexion les inflexions
sont faites aujourd'hui sur les 3%, je
vous ferai remarquer que elle elle s'est
présentée aux primaires du Parti
socialiste en disant qu'il ne fallait
pas avoir
une position dogmatique sur les 3%
aujourd'hui
et ce mercredi pour finir les syndicats
avaient rendez-vous avec le ministre du
Travail François Rebsamen au menu des
discussions notamment le pack de
responsabilité mais aussi les seuils
sociaux Jean-Christophe Cambadélis vous
étiez exprimé contre François mène
contre l'allègement de ces sociaux et
pourtant ça va se faire visiblement en
tout cas en discussion avec les
syndicats qu'est-ce qui se passe qui a
raison qui attend vous continuez à avoir
votre position et s'il y a besoin je
réunirai le bureau national en formation
extraordinaire il nous attendons notre
position c'est-à-dire est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu détailler
j'ai expliqué que j'étais contre je
continue à être contre
le gouvernement qu'il y ait des
négociations qu'il y ait des
négociations entre partenaires sociaux
je m'y oppose pas mais que l'on passe en
force contre les partenaires sociaux je
m'y oppose donc réunion du bureau
national s'il le faut position du parti
je me suis exprimé dans le monde il y a
quelques semaines en disant que je j'ai
été suffisamment sévère avec les
frondeurs et je le saurai vis-à-vis de
toute position sociale libérale alors on
quitte la scène nationale pour
l'environnement international avec jeudi
Barack Obama qui déclare la guerre à
l'état islamique
il l'a dit il combattra les djihadistes
jusqu'en Syrie le président américain a
donné son feu vert et son plan de
bataille pour une intervention en Irak
pas de troupe au sol mais des frappes
aériennes et la France sera au premier
plan avec François Hollande en chef de
guerre Marie Bermot
en janvier 2013 l'armée française part à
la reconquête du Mali en partie occupée
par des islamistes armés l'opération
Serval est la plus importante opération
militaire française depuis 50 ans drex
qui a surpris par exemple c'est la
rapidité de la réaction notamment au
moment de l'opération malienne qui sait
décider en 48 heures
et c'est vrai que c'est quand même
effectivement un petit peu une une
surprise de voir
Hollande être devenu un chef de guerre
peut-être bien malgré lui mais en tout
cas effectivement il est devenu à l'été
2013 François Hollande plaide pour une
intervention en Syrie avec ses alliés
mais lâché par les États-Unis la France
se retrouve isolée et le président de la
République est obligé de faire
volte-face suite à ce revers
diplomatique François Hollande chef des
armées attend le vote de l'ONU pour
ouvrir un autre front cette fois en
République centrafricaine afin d'éviter
un génocide l'opération sangariste est
lancée en décembre 2013 sous l'égide de
la France en un an et demi François
Hollande sur la scène européenne et
internationale s'est posée en chef de
guerre encore aujourd'hui la France
s'est dit prête à participer à une
coalition en Irak étant également de
convaincre ses alliés d'agir en Libye
décidément il y a beaucoup de
d'opérations engagées par la France et
par François Hollande chef des armées
est-ce que François Hollande est
meilleur chef de guerre que Nicolas
Sarkozy
prononcerait pas là dessus il est
confronté à des nécessités et des
situations auxquelles l'ancien président
ne l'était pas je veux dire aujourd'hui
un état islamique entre Bagdad et Damas
Nicolas Sarkozy ne l'avait pas vu enfin
elle avait pas vu c'était pas une
situation qui s'était présentée à lui et
je pense que la France
le personnalisons pas la France a un
rôle de plus en plus important dans le
bassin méditerranéen dans le moment où
les Américains s'en vont plutôt vers le
Pacifique et de décider seul et de ne
pas être l'exécutant le simple exécutant
des États-Unis parce qu'entre l'affaire
des mistrales et aujourd'hui les frappes
en Syrie on a l'impression qu'elle se
contente de suivre les États-Unis du
même registre
sur les décisions il vaut mieux sur
l'action il vaut mieux faire des
coalitions et vaut mieux avoir l'accord
des Nations Unies la France jusqu'à
présent n'a pas agi seul elle a eu
l'accord des Nations Unies sur le par
exemple ou sur la Centrafrique
mais il faut que la France continue à
occuper son rang
dans le MES bassins méditerranéen et en
même temps je trouve que à travers cela
si l'Allemagne et la réalité économique
aujourd'hui de l'Europe la France en est
son esprit de la provocation de on a
l'impression que le costume de chef de
guerre lui va mieux finalement que le
costume de chef de la majorité à
François Hollande bon je dirais pas ça
vous savez c'est assez simple de quand
vous êtes dans la Cinquième République
et que vous avez des décisions à prendre
de ce style c'est plus compliqué quand
vous avez administré un pays qui était
au point de départ dans un état
épouvantable et que vous essayez de
redresser voilà c'est tout simple est-ce
que c'est vraiment le rôle de la France
d'intervenir de frapper en Irak alors
même que la situation économique est
difficile et que engager des frappes
aériennes comme ça avec autant de moyens
à rien ça coûte cher écoutez si nous le
faisions pas je reprends ce que vous me
diriez à ce moment vous direz voilà il y
a 1000 terroristes potentiels en Irak
ils vont revenir en France et la France
ne fait rien elle reste les bras croisés
vous allez avoir des attentats en France
et vous ne dites rien voilà
de faire face à l'ensemble des
difficultés peut-être pas peut-être
demain ça sera plus possible
ce n'est pas anormal mais ceci dit ils
ont pu mener à bien l'ensemble des
missions que nous leur avons confié
jusqu'à présent pas demain ce ne sera
plus le cas ce qui disent c'est bien
et le livre blanc a été adopté et
respecté donc dans un cadre budgétaire
contraint contre un ce que les autres
nations d'Europe ne font pas nous
assumons notre rang je vous propose de
revenir un petit peu sur la politique
mais de façon différente par le biais du
théâtre
vous connaissiez évidemment les séries
télé et notamment américaines qui se
passionnent pour le dessous des cartes
en politique cette fois c'est le théâtre
qui nous fait découvrir une pièce digne
des séries américaines comme House of
Cards et pour cause celui qui a écrit
House of Cards et celui qui écrit cette
pièce les cartes du pouvoir c'est en ce
moment au théâtre héberto à Paris Simon
barbarie s'est régalé regardez
présidentiel je te veux j'ai besoin des
meilleurs je vais t'appeler tout droit
au sommet parce que tu es le meilleur ah
tu déconnes j'en ai fait des qui
m'empêche de dormir la nuit mais alors
ça trahison couteau du mensonge et
manipulation c'est le quotidien d'une
campagne électorale telle qu'il est
dépeints dans la pièce les cartes du
pouvoir les acteurs Raphaël Personnaz et
Thierry Frémont incarnent deux
conseillers de l'ombre d'un candidat
démocrate aux primaire des États-Unis et
question crédibilité qui de mieux que
vos willymon l’auteur de la pièce plus
connu en tant que scénariste de la
célèbre série House of Cards
dans le monde politique qui en parle
très bien donc toutes les toutes les
sources toutes les informations on a
juste à dire le texte pour comprendre un
peu dans quoi on évolue quoi c'est c'est
très clair ce qui est limpide c'est le
poids de plus le plus important compris
ces hommes de l'ombre dans les sphères
du pouvoir jusqu'à faire malgré eux la
une de l'actualité
les hommes de l'ombre qui se mettent
dans la lumière c'est peut-être ça le
problème pour votre entourage politique
je n'ai pas d'homme de long je n'ai pas
de conseils en communication
oui mais je les trouve très peu présent
autour du président de la République et
du Premier ministre
à l'époque de François Mitterrand qui en
avait plus ça nous montre aussi c'est le
paradoxe
si on voulait être objectif et analyser
les choses François Mitterrand et
Jacques Chirac et bilan
collé et quelques autres qui étaient des
spécialistes
au début des années 80 je
trouve c'est très américain mais je
trouve que c'est en retard qu'il y a une
reprise en main
du politique du politique sur leur
communication c'est pas toujours réussi
d'ailleurs sur leur communication et sur
leur expression c'est important d'être
bien entouré mais ça vous pouvez être
bien entouré
oui mais bon ça vous ne savez pas mais
mais il faut être bien entouré mais il
faut être bien entouré tout le temps ça
vaut dans une entreprise
dans votre Chaîne parlementaire ou du
président aujourd'hui
la communication du Président elle est
elle est assez simple d'un certain point
de vue elle n'a pas de floritures il y a
pas de coup
etc donc on pourrait le reprocher de ne
pas assez travailler comme communication
mais c'est lui qui l'a dirige il y a pas
de Sping doctor vous pouvez chercher
là-bas
mot de la fin pour cette émission merci
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis d'avoir été
l'invité de Parlement Hebdo bonne
semaine à tous à la semaine prochaine
Ciao